[Music]
on-screen gangsters real-life civil
rights activists and extraordinary
comedians gone too soon adam sandler has
shared the screen with many legendary
entertainers but do you know who he
considers the funniest here are some of
the sandman's latest and greatest
co-stars although he's almost certainly
best known as the notorious
steel-toothed bond villain jaws from
1977's the spy who loved me and 1979's
moonraker richard kiel made an
unforgettable appearance alongside
sandler in happy gilmore at seven feet
two inches kill perfectly played the
behemoth spectator in the gallery at
gilmore's tournament despite his
intimidating presence kill's character
added a great deal of comedy to the film
by hilariously crossing paths with
gilmore's rival shooter mcgavin played
by christopher mcdonald apparently he
and sandler developed a great bond while
on set when kill passed away in
september 2014 sandler mourned the loss
of his pal on twitter saying richard
keel was one of the nicest funniest guys
i've ever met i'll never forget hanging
out with him and how good he was to
everyone it is believed that the
towering actor died of a heart attack
but tmz also reported a death
certificate indicating that he also had
coronary artery disease regardless of
the cause of his ultimate demise kiel
will always be remembered as one of the
greatest of hollywood's giants
ray leota's death in may 2022 rocked the
world the mega talented actor best known
for playing protagonist henry hill and
martin scorsese's 1990 gangster classic
goodfellas passed away in his sleep
while working on the upcoming movie
dangerous waters he was 67 years old
with a slew of movie credits and
impressive awards including an emmy win
for outstanding guest actor in a drama
series thanks to his work in er while
leota's death is pretty common knowledge
at this point some fans might be
surprised to learn that he actually
starred in one of adam sandler's netflix
movies before he died in 2020's huby
halloween the shades of blue actor
played pete landolfa one of huby's many
bullies but he did love to laugh okay
and i know he will get a great chuckle
out of this
although leota's character in the flick
was a major jerk sandler noted that he
was the polar opposite in real life
after the actor's death sandler took to
twitter to memorialize his friend he
expressed appreciation for leota's
acting as well as his parenting and
sense of humor it seems the on-screen
tough guy was quite the renaissance man
one could argue that some of sandler's
best works are the romantic comedies he
stars in alongside drew barrymore 1998's
the wedding singer 2004's 51st dates and
2014's blended are all heartwarming and
hilarious films where the stars bring
out the best in each other notably
barrymore and sandler were almost always
joined by another actor when they teamed
up for these movies alexis arquette
arquette was a talented character actor
and major transgender activist who
transitioned into a woman in 2004 sadly
she passed away in late 2016 after
suffering a heart attack while also
stricken with aids in their statement
about her death her siblings patricia
rosanna richmond and david arquette
praised her for living her truth saying
despite the fact that there are few
parts for trans actors she refused to
play roles that were demeaning or
stereotypical she was a vanguard in the
fight for understanding and acceptance
for all trans people arquette's final
appearance in a future film before she
died was actually blended whereas she
had a brief cameo as georgina stitzer
and homage to the character she played
in the wedding singer in both movies she
played a boy george impersonator and she
actually did it so well george himself
tweeted that she was quote another
bright light going out far too soon when
he learned of her passing
while losing someone always hurts
there's arguably nothing worse than
losing someone who still has a whole
life ahead of them that's precisely what
happened to disney channel breakout star
cameron boyce who in 2019 died of sudden
unexpected death in epilepsy at the
young age of 20. boyce was probably best
known for his role in disney tv shows
like descendants and jesse but he also
starred as adam sandler's son keithy in
the highly lucrative grown-ups franchise
when speaking to young hollywood the
teenage star admitted that sandler was
one of the first people he felt star
struck by boyce noted that when he first
met sandler at age nine the older actors
trademark immature jokes were right up
his alley
i
knew of him very well
a nine-year-old likes their fart jokes
so
he's good at those
however the bond clearly developed into
something deeper as the comedian took
boyce's passing incredibly hard on
social media sandler expressed how
heartbroken he was that such a kind and
talented young actor passed away so
early into his career sandler even
honored boyce in the credits of huby
halloween a few minutes after the film
ends a picture of the late actor appears
on the screen as well as a heartfelt
tribute which reads you live on forever
in our hearts and are truly missed every
day
it's possible that adam sandler has
worked with more top-notch comedians
than anyone else in hollywood history
however during the most touching song of
his uniquely musical netflix special 100
fresh he pointly sings that he considers
chris farley the funniest person he's
ever worked with farley and the sandman
were incredibly close buddies they came
up together on saturday night live in
the early 1990s outside of countless
hilarious snl sketches the duo
co-starred together in coneheads
airheads and billy madison in billy
madison farley absolutely steals every
scene as the wildly unhinged bus driver
arguably providing more infamous lines
than any other character in that movie
the man was truly a one-of-a-kind
comedic talent
everybody on good great grand wonderful
no yelling on the bus
tragically many comedy fans know that
farley's wild man personality came with
great consequences on december 18 1997
he was found dead in his apartment due
to an accidental drug overdose he was
only 33 years old
1999's big daddy has one of the most
tear-jerking scenes in any adam sandler
movie in the film it's established that
sandler's character sunny has an
estranged relationship with his father
played by oscar-nominated screenwriter
and actor joseph bologna the character's
relationship is tested when during a
hearing to establish whether or not
sonny was a good father to his adopted
son julian he asks his dad to question
him it's a truly powerful scene that
still tugs on the heartstrings of many
fathers and sons today while big daddy
was bologna's only appearance in a
sandler flick it was most definitely a
memorable one so much so that when
bologna passed away in 2017 many people
celebrated the role specifically despite
the fact that he'd been starring in tv
shows and movies since 1971 according to
the hollywood reporter bologna died from
pancreatic cancer at the age of 82.
if you watched any sitcoms in the 1990s
there's a good chance you saw mary pat
gleason in action the talented actress
was seemingly everywhere during the era
appearing in huge shows like saved by
the bell friends and will and grace she
also starred in a plethora of movies
throughout her lengthy career ranging
from teenage rom-coms like 2004's a
cinderella story to historic dramas like
1996's the crucible although she had
great range gleason's forte was in the
world of comedy she just had a natural
ability to make people laugh and she
didn't need a big part to do so for
example in the two adam sandler movies
she popped up in 2007's i now pronounce
you chuck and larry in 2014's blended
leeson's lines were very limited however
she still contributed to some of the
film's biggest laughs good morning uncle
chuck
what's doing guys good morning teresa
great morning
unknown to most gleason did most of her
later acting after being diagnosed with
cancer and she ultimately succumbed to
it in june 2020 joining a slew of other
actors and actresses that we lost that
year in a statement her manager
confirmed that she was an incredibly
tough woman fighting through her pain to
finish out her roles in mom and the
blacklist she is most certainly missed
in early 2021 the world was rocked with
the news that cloris leachman treasured
actress and comedian had passed away due
to natural causes over the course of the
oscar-winning star's 70-year career
leachman earned more than 280 film and
tv credits in the process she performed
alongside some of hollywood's most elite
celebrities including gene wilder to
paul newman another one of leachman's
reputable co-stars was adam sandler it's
easy to forget that the young
frankenstein actress actually popped up
in not one but two of the sandman's
movies in 2004's moody romantic drama
spanglish leachman played evelyn
sandler's alcoholic mother-in-law one
year later she took on a small but quite
hilarious role in 2005's remake of the
longest yard wherein she played the
warden's assistant with an especially
aggressive crush on sandler's character
paul crew the pair had a natural
chemistry that apparently extended even
after the camera stopped rolling when
sandler learned of leachman's passing he
tweeted a memorial to her which said
cloris leachman a true legend one of the
funniest of all time and such a great
lady loved her will be missed terribly
that's quite high praise coming from
someone who has made movies with so many
a-list comedians throughout his career
although she's likely best known for
playing sassy housekeeper berta in over
200 episodes of two and a half men
conchata pharaoh starred in loads of
popular movies and tv shows throughout
her decades-long acting career her
filmography boasts credits from popular
shows like l.a law buffy the vampire
slayer and grayson frankie and she was
even nominated for emmy awards on three
separate occasions she also starred as
the no-nonsense jan alongside adam
sandler in 2002's quirky comedy mr deeds
farrell's great run all came to an end
in october 2020 however when she passed
away from medical complications at the
age of 77 following a cardiac arrest
some of her old co-stars and celebrity
friends took to social media to express
their sympathy over the terrible news
including two and a half men stars
charlie sheen and john cryer sandler
himself even posted a tweet celebrating
the actress and extending his
condolences to her family
one of adam sandler's many talents is
his ability to seamlessly combine laughs
and sports with films like happy gilmore
and the longest yard the sandman has
been responsible for helping create some
of the most memorable sports comedies of
all time however his most quotable
sports movie was easily 1998's timeless
classic the waterboy sandless stars his
good-hearted mama's boy bobby boucher an
off-bullied water boy for the university
of louisiana football team after he's
fired from ul bobby's given a second
chance by coach klein played by henry
winkler and his south central louisiana
state university mud dogs where he
learns that his place on the gridiron is
actually on the field sadly some members
of the iconic cast are no longer with us
jerry reid who perfectly captured coach
klein's fiercely competitive nemesis red
bull you passed away in 2008 due to
emphysema a dangerous lung condition
reid was not only a talented actor
starring as cletus snow in three smokey
and the bandit films but also a
chart-topping country music star during
his music career he took home three
grammy awards and was even inducted into
the country music hall of fame in 2017.
talk about an impressive legacy to leave
behind
you might not know it from his small
role as the frequently intoxicated mr
haralee in big daddy but edmund lindeck
was once a big time broadway star he was
actually the very first actor to bring
the evil judge turpin to life in stephen
sondheim's timeless revenge musical
sweeney todd the demon barber of fleet
street he went on to star in several
other plays during his time on stage
while broadway was clearly his forte
lindeck did dip his toes into film and
television he popped up in small roles
in disney's enchanted and the raunchy
teen comedy road trip he also appeared
in a few tv shows including an episode
of law and order special victims unit
notably big daddy wasn't the only time
he collaborated with sandler nearly a
decade later lindeck also made a cameo
in 2008 you don't mess with the zohan
according to playbill lindeck passed
away on december 14 2015 at the age of
90 though the cause of death was not
specified
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
adam sandler movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]